hi everyone uh i'm worried samuels the
director of the yale program for the
study of anti-semitism and i'm really
happy to welcome you here today to our
benjamin and barbara zucker lecture
series today's speaker mark oppenheimer
is the author of five books including
knocking on heaven's door american
religion in the age of counterculture
which was based on his
2003 dissertation in yale's religious
studies department winner of that year's
porter prize he was the religion
columnist for the new york times from
2010 to 2016 and is written for the new
york times magazine gq mother jones the
nation and the atlantic among other
publications the host of tablet
magazines podcast unorthodox oppenheimer
is taught at stanford wellesley and yale
where since 2006 he has directed the
yale journalism initiative he lives with
his family in new haven connecticut and
currently teaches daily themes in the
english department at yale
last october he published his new book
squirrel hill the tree of life synagogue
shooting and the soul of the
neighborhood which he researched with
funding from our program and that is
also the title of his talk today
so let me just say a word about how
things are going to work
mark will speak for about 30 minutes and
then we'll have about 20
to 25 minutes of questions from the
audience so please submit your questions
using the q a function at the bottom of
your screen
don't raise your hand because we can't
see you
uh now please join me in welcoming mark
oppenheimer
uh maurice thank you so much it's it's a
great honor to be here and um i would uh
first of all just very quickly like to
thank um the yell program in the study
of anti-semitism for funding this
project in part and now for having me
back uh to to talk to all of you about
it and maurice and anessa leskova at the
uh at the department at the program i
also want to thank the zucker family for
having endowed this lecture series that
has me that's having me here today as it
happens i have a history with ben zucker
because he um among other things among
in addition to being himself the author
of some very fine books
he is a jeweler who years ago uh
provided the setting for the engagement
ring that i gave my wife um and so far
the marriage has lasted so i figure you
know there was it was it all worked out
well as well that ends well so um i
haven't seen him in a while but it's
it's good to be here and i hope i hope
he's here today um i actually know that
he tried to reach out to me yesterday
and i wasn't able to connect but it it's
good to be to be back with him in that
sense
um
so i want to i want to say a little bit
today about the book and then i'm going
to
read two pages from it then i'm going to
share about a dozen photographs from it
because it is a a fairly richly
illustrated book which was very
important to me and then i'm going to
read one or two more pages and all told
that's going to take about half an hour
at most and then i really want to leave
ample time for all of your questions
because i think that's
for me sort of that
part
i've heard myself talk a lot over the
past few months and i and i haven't
heard from most of you at all and i
think every time i speak i i get new
questions and new provocations and and
and people who enrich my own thinking
about this topic
um
along the way
so let me first tell you where i was on
october 27 2018 in in the morning which
was the morning of the deadliest
anti-semitic attack in american history
when 11 jews were killed inside the tree
of life synagogue building out of the 22
people who were inside the building that
day so there were 22 people half of whom
did not make it out alive
um
it was um
a cold october morning in newton
massachusetts where i was with my
daughter
and my eldest daughter she had been
invited to the botnets of a summer camp
friend of hers
and uh so we were up at temple emanuel
in newton massachusetts two hours or so
from our home in new haven we were
inside synagogue all morning and so we
did not um
we did not have technology with us we
don't bring phones into synagogue on the
sabbath uh in our family and i assume
that because there were hundreds of
people inside the building and it's not
a an extremely religious congregation
there were certainly people there who
had their phones out at some point and
probably knew what was happening in
pittsburgh but if so they didn't tell us
and and rebecca and i didn't know when
we got back out to my car in the parking
lot at about one in the afternoon
i did open up my phone to see if my wife
had reached us and uh
i had all these text messages from
people saying are you going to
pittsburgh
what's that you know what do you know
about pittsburgh
can you find out more about pittsburgh
and i thought why are all these people
texting me about pittsburgh so then i
navigated over to my news app and i saw
what had happened and i must have looked
very very stricken because my daughter
rebecca
said to me um
she said dad is everything okay
and i said well
no i said there's been
a shooting and and some jews are dead in
squirrel hill
and
rebecca said um squirrel hill isn't that
where we're from
and i said well in a sense yes because
what she understood
uh even though she herself is from new
haven and uh i am from springfield
massachusetts she knew that her grandpa
my dad
was from squirrel hill and i think she
may even have known from family lord
that he was the third generation to be
from the squirrel hill neighborhood of
pittsburgh and the fifth generation to
be from pittsburgh in fact uh so the
oppenheimers got to pittsburgh in the
1840s
and were in other parts slightly western
parts of the city
uh for two generations and then as soon
as squirrel who was developed around the
time of world war one they settled in
squirrel hill and had been there ever
since so it was the family and is the
family homeland it's where it's where
her people are from
so we were very very very torn apart and
over um the coming days i thought a lot
about what it meant to be from this
neighborhood and increasingly
my mind kept going to the neighborhood
itself because although
there have been very good books about
the um
the perpetrators of anti-semitic attacks
um and of mass terror indeed um in mass
shootings of which there have been
hundreds in the united states since
columbine in 1999.
what i realized
i didn't know enough about and what i
immediately got curious about as a
journalist and a scholar was not the
mind of the killer which i wasn't really
interested in spending time researching
for obvious reasons and indeed it wasn't
even the 11 who had been killed who i'm
sure were beautiful souls each of whom
might deserve a book of their own but
what i kept coming back to given my own
pre-existing interest was the question
of the neighborhood because i knew
squirrel hill history and i knew that it
was uh arguably the oldest most stable
jewish neighborhood in uh american
history which is something we can we can
talk about later
uh it had been substantively jewish
about a third give or take
consistently for a hundred years for
from the time of world war one until the
pres so a century exactly and that's not
something you could say of any other
neighborhood in the united states uh it
had always been a neighborhood
relatively free of anti-semitism even
though jews had been
a minority um so it has always been
gentile majority and yet it's been a
plea for jews that felt safe and
pittsburgh indeed has been a place
relatively free of anti-semitism so the
irony that the deadliest anti-semitic
attack would come to
squirrel hill was not lost on me and i
got very very interested in how the
neighborhood
in part the neighborhood's religious
congregations because there are many
jewish synagogues in squirrel hill and
also other houses of worship but really
the neighborhood more broadly
was going to cope what would it mean to
a neighborhood so
um
armed with this question a terrible
metaphor armed but with this question
let's say i began going to pittsburgh uh
the month after the shooting you know in
november within a few weeks i made my
first trip and i ended up going 32 times
and interviewing about 250 people over
18 months and i stopped reporting just
as kovit was descending across the land
in march of 2020 though that was
entirely coincidental i had planned for
several months that march would be about
my stopping point because i'd be coming
up on 18 months and i really had
more than enough interviews and
reporting already and i i had planned
already to stop about then
so
with these hundreds of interviews and
these uh several dozen trips i wrote
this book that's really about
um the concentric circles of people
affected by a tragedy that in in the
kind of
in the herb of a neighborhood um and in
in the kind of grid of life of a
neighborhood that's walkable bikeable
that has people naturally colliding into
each other
because of commerce because of religious
worship because of public institutions
like schools and
post office and
supermarkets and so forth and so on the
public library all of the squirrel hill
has all these things it's a kind of
urban uh shadow a kind of idyllic
village what would that mean for how
people reacted uh to grief
and the book that i wrote is a kind of
patchwork of portraits of the people
who become relevant
outside of the scope of the national
media and even sometimes outside the
scope of the archivists and historians
who come and naturally and for good
reason gravitate toward uh families of
the victims the survivors uh clergy
people people who have a kind of
official status i was not as interested
in people with official status so what
i'd like to do now is read to you again
just two pages and then i want to take
you through some photographs and then
we'll read another bit more
the two pages that i want to read you
from are from the the prologue to the
book
and it's where
i learned the story of a woman
named tammy happs who becomes something
of a through line through the book she's
a harvard graduate about 40 years old
when this all happens
grew up outside philadelphia in cherry
hill new jersey but had migrated to
pittsburgh in recent years because she
was an amateur genealogist whose
grandparents had been from homestead
which is right across the river a steel
town outside of pittsburgh and she was
doing a lot of geological research so
she'd become very embedded in
pittsburgh's jewish community she had
moved to squirrel hill she'd been there
the better part of a decade
and in the 24 hours after the killing
really the 48 hours 72 hours she was
everywhere she was at the jewish
community center consoling someone who
had lost her husband uh in the shooting
she was part of a group of members of
ben the ark the progressive jewish
organization that drafted a letter
asking that donald trump not come to
visit
she was saying psalms to heal him
outside of tree of life synagogue while
the bodies were still inside because a
jewish tradition is that when keeping
guard over dead bodies you you recite
psalms she had done that and finally
completely wiped out she is trudging
home
on sunday afternoon
and this is what happens to her so have
a listen for about three minutes
just after 2 30
she turned onto murray avenue and a
truck pulled up in front of her
on the side of it were painted three
curious words
crosses for losses
as tammy happs remembered it she looked
into the truck and saw a pile of crosses
in the back christian crosses they were
all white
and on a quick count she decided there
were 11 of them
as soon as she grasped what she was
seeing she was incensed
i thought to myself perhaps recalled you
have got to be [ __ ] kidding me
and i looked around and no one else was
there and i thought if i have to be the
one to tell this man he can't put
crosses on the synagogue property i will
be the one to tell him
peps had no idea who this guy was with
this kind of nerve
as she was figuring out what to say to
him trying to keep her cool she saw on
the front seat of his truck a pile of
wooden six-pointed stars
she was relieved
i thought okay what will happen is he'll
put the stars of david on the fronts of
the crosses and it will be okay
greg's venus got out on the driver's
side of the truck and approached tammy
hepz
she looked him up and down he was tired
unshaven old what was he doing here
where did he come from then she looked
down and saw his hands and it was as if
something became clear
i saw his hands were covered in white
paint perhaps remembered it's like he
painted these things overnight and
didn't even have time to wash his hands
he told me his intention he said to me i
made these things got my truck and drove
nine hours
i've been driving the whole time
i don't even know the names the people
who died
i have to write their names on the stars
and then haps knew what she had to do
her mother had emailed her the names of
the dead just that morning so she had
the names on her phone
joyce feinberg richard gottfried rose
mallinger jerry rabinowitz cecil
rosenthal david rosenthal bernice simon
sylvan simon daniel stein melvin wax erv
younger
i brought up this list she recalled and
he said to me can you please write the
names in my notebook
and as he handed me a pen and his
notebook i was shaking as i copied the
names down so he could write them on the
stars
when happs had written down all 11 names
she gave zanus his notebook back to him
and now she had a question for him
i said to him why do you do this
and he said that there'd been gun
violence in his family and this was his
response
he said you remember parkland
i did that one
remember columbine
i did that one too
it had never occurred to me peps told me
that it was one person who had made it
his life's work to drive around the
country and do this
and at that moment i realized that we
were just another one on the list
so that's tammy heps's encounter with
greg zaynus who's non-profit
organization crosses for losses which
was a non-profit of one it was just him
uh
traveled around the country constantly
putting up these white crosses
at the sites of mass tragedy and again
that's just a kind of example of the
people who arrive and create the who add
color
to
and create the the effect and the mood
in the aftermath of a mass killing and i
want to show you some pictures now
um so
here you can see the cover
of my book and it actually didn't occur
to me when i first saw it and it's a
beautiful cover
how symbolically interesting it was it
read as a text
what you see is the scene outside tree
of life about 48 hours after the killing
more than 48 because it was the evening
and you see that already it's become a
shrine a memorial to the dead
but what's interesting here is the way
that it's become an interfaith memorial
because the candles that you see the
little tea candles are of course a
jewish sign of mourning right you know
jews light these candles on yard sight
and on the the anniversaries of people's
deaths
we of course also use jews ritually for
to bring in the sabbath to leave the
sabbath and so forth so candles are very
liturgically jewish
flowers are not flowers actually are a
part of the american and christian
idioms and and of course christians will
bring flowers to gravesides which jews
will typically not they'll bring candles
or they'll bring stones they we put
stones on graves but typically not
flowers except in so far as in america
that's something people do but already
you can see that you have a kind of a
jewish semiotics and a christian
semi-eyes tropes of both of both of
those communities coming together in
this very very beautiful makeshift kind
of memorial garden outside of tree of
life within just a couple days
this is greg zanus the one i just talked
about he put
millions of miles on a whole series of
pickup trucks that he drove into the
ground from 1995 or six when he first
made uh some some crosses for a woman in
his grief support group who had lost her
son zanus had lost his father-in-law as
i recall
and then columbine happened a few years
later and he started driving around the
country and he went to every mass
killing he could also he went to the
sites of natural disasters he went to
the sites of uh you know people who'd
been killed in tornadoes hurricanes um
you know huge traffic fatalities things
like that
um and he
he was an evangelical christian himself
but he always tried to be culturally
sensitive he would do things like put
the star of david on the front of the
cross if he knew that the victim was
jewish he also would put a crescent moon
if he knew that the victim was muslim he
knew appropriate symbols for sikhs and
baha'i and hindu and shinto he even had
a symbol and i forget what it was if he
heard that the victim was an atheist or
an agnostic
so he was very very sensitive and he
became a kind of one-man emissary of
interfaith death craft if you will he
himself died in december of 2020 and you
could find his his obituary in the new
york times i was very interested in the
way that visual culture was shaped by
the aftermath of a of a mass killing you
everywhere you go whether it was the
bombing in boston or whether it's
parkland or whatever there ends up
becoming something that's this kind of
visual representation by by mutual mass
agreement and in pittsburgh it was this
this symbol which most of you have have
seen
and it's um it's
it was created by a graphic designer
named tim hines not spelled like heinz
ketchup which is of course one of the
great pittsburgh companies it's about
h-i-n-d-e-s
and he's a uh elapsed lutheran you know
gentile german-american
graphic designer who lived in the south
suburbs of pittsburgh didn't know anyone
at trivia of life
not kind of involved in interfaith work
or the jewish community just a
kind of
christian american
dude who um wanted to do something to
help and he's driving home
listening to this on the radio he had
been he happened to be in pittsburgh
that morning when it happened
allison he fires up his macintosh and
thinks as a graphic designer what can i
do and he wants to create uh something
that represents the way that pittsburgh
embraces its jews so he thinks well
what's pittsburgh and he thinks what's
more pittsburgh than the pittsburgh
steelers so he takes the logo of the
pittsburgh steelers
and then he replaces the yellow
hypocycloid at the top that's what those
shapes are called as i learned in
reporting this book he replaces it with
a yellow star of david to kind of mash
up the pittsburghery and the jewelry and
then he replaces the word steelers with
the word stronger than hate playing on
boston strong orlando strong and other
terms you hear and catch phrases in the
aftermath of a mass killing he puts it
on facebook within a few hours it's gone
around the world a trillion times or so
the next day at the steelers game people
are holding up posters with this you
know this logo on them the steelers end
up
wearing it on their cleats you can find
it on babies onesies you can find it on
yamaka's and and perhaps most movingly
it ends up being posted in the windows
of storefronts throughout squirrel hill
all along the forbes and murray
commercial corridor and again created by
somebody not jewish but you know lives
uh 10 to 20 miles from
the site of the killing and it ends up
kind of becoming
this jewish but also jewish pittsburgh
interfaith intercommunal
symbol
another one of those iconic symbols was
the headline of the pittsburgh post
gazette on the friday after the killings
now keep in mind the the 11 victims who
were from three different congregations
that that were housed at the tree of
life building were buried over four days
so there were 11 funerals over four days
in a neighborhood uh you know less than
three square miles constant crowds and
and traffic snarls and people trying to
get from place to place and just a
neighborhood suffused with grief this
headline ran on the last day of the
funerals friday morning and what's so
interesting is david truman now retired
but who was the editor-in-chief of the
post-gazette
he um
he had this idea to run the hebrew for
the first line of the kaddish the
mourner's prayer the jews say the first
line being yitkadav
hallowed and exalted be the name
and uh be the great the great name right
um
and um
he didn't know how to spell it in hebrew
and he called his rabbi at a different
temple not tree of life he's a member of
temple sinai and rabbi gibson sent him
the text
in an email
so sherman then as i learned took it to
his graphic designer uh his chief
designer at the post gazette and said
make a headline out of this and she said
we actually don't have a hebrew font
that big we don't have a hebrew headline
typeface at the post gazette so they had
to kind of create it from scratch uh
right there they got it up
and the next day friday morning it hit
people's new you know doorsteps and
newsstands and and people just broke
into tears it was so beautiful so
perfect so completely uh iconic
another one of those images that i think
will survive this one forever quite
literally is um the window of the
starbucks at the corner of forbes and
shady the busier of the two starbucks in
squirrel hill the
last presbyterian starbucks manager
melissa lysat wanted to do something for
her heavily jewish clientele who she
knew were grieving so she called her
roman catholic friend nicole flannery
and said can you do something jewish for
the windows nicole flannery is a local
artist so flannery um connected with an
orthodox jewish man and asked him for
advice on what to do and he gave her the
idea for the star of david the tree of
life and the dove and then he helped her
with the words
love kindness and hope and she painted
this over the next few days and it went
up around tuesday morning and people it
was like you know birds flying into
windows that they people just
stopped or they just kept walking and
walked into the woods they were so
mesmerized they bumped into each other
on the sidewalk and these are still
there these the this these windows i
think will be there forever and i just
love the idea that 35 years from now
there will be teenagers inside that
starbucks looking at the reverse image
and saying what the heck is that in the
window
you know they're sipping their
frappuccinos they don't know about the
shooting and somebody some you know old
hand inside the starbucks will explain
to them why
these these words and images are in the
starbucks window
i took this photograph which is why it's
terrible i'm a poor photographer
composition is bad this is the
sign off the highway as you drive up
forward avenue to the base of murray and
enter squirrel hill and if you look at
the h in squirrel hill you'll see that a
little star of david is hanging from it
a little uh
you know glitter paper star of david
this is one of thousands of stars of
david very small you know a few inches
across that had been handmade and and
collected from around the world
some were made of popsicle sticks some
were made of school projects out of
you know cut paper some were knit or or
crocheted or macrame or paper mache and
you name it and they were collected
through a facebook group that then in
november went around and hung them all
over the city from signs from statuary
from trees
and they didn't most of them didn't last
the winter because of the weather but of
course in the winter you could look up
sometimes
if you were on forbes avenue let's say
and there'd be a light snow
and
the
street lamps would be reflecting off the
snow and then off of these these stars
and it was as if the stars were
representing the dead as if there were
thousands of angels um in in the sky
above the streets it was just so
beautiful this was the last one i saw in
march it was still hanging there and i
would always check when i was driving
into town is that star still there
and then the next week after i took this
photo it wasn't there it was on the
ground in the mud and i i found it i
have it so but it was kind of a
worldwide project right so all of a
sudden there's a kind of homely hamish
public art created around the world that
ends up decorating um
squirrel hill in pittsburgh which i just
think is a kind of beautiful effect and
very very very contemporary
i include this photograph just because
it's important to note that there are
orthodox jews walking with the hearse of
one of the victims on the way to the
internment
none of the victims was orthodox and yet
a lot of the people who helped with the
grieving process in various ways acting
as shamrim for example as guards over
the bodies in some cases cleansing the
bodies performing the ritual of tahara
were orthodox and that kind of not just
inter-religious cooperation but
intra-religious cooperation is quite
rare one of the interesting things i
found is that squirrel hill has a very
unusual level of amity amongst the
different jewish denominations which is
something that that really does bear
further study
another thing that happens after a mass
killing is a lot of money comes in
some of it is raised by quasi-official
organizations in this case the jewish
federation of greater pittsburgh but it
but some of it is raised by solo
operators this is shai khatiri an
ex-muslim iranian expatriate now living
inside the beltway down in washington
doing a masters
at one of the johns hopkins programs on
uh in d.c
he um he woke up that morning he heard
what had happened he was sick sick to
his stomach he went to a local coffee
shop and opened up
a gofundme.org page to raise money
and within a few days it had raised a
million and a half dollars for the jews
of of squirrel well for the for tree of
life and the victims families and so
forth for the congregations and the
families
making him i think one of the
probably the largest single fundraiser
non-jewish fundraiser for the jewish
community of squirrel hill ever
uh when i asked him to provide a photo
of himself he sent me this picture of
himself standing in front of the white
house holding plato's republic which i
think tells you about how he sees
himself and his commitment to to western
civilization and wanting to be part of
the american project
a group of teenagers seniors at taylor
alderdice high school the big public
high school in squirrel hill gathered at
that starbucks to organize a vigil that
night it happened you know six or seven
hours after the crime scene was was
secured
and uh it was a havdallah ritual um the
ritual that brings out the sabbath that
ends saturday
and here you can see emily pressman
holding the dollar candle
an observant jewish girl woman uh she's
in college now they were high school
seniors at the time to the right of her
is isabelle smith who was a classmate of
hers
um at aldredice
biracial ancestrally christian though
she told me she's not particularly
religious
and it gives you a sense of you know the
interfaith nature again of the healing
what these girls did along with some
boys um was pull out several thousand
people to the heart of the squirrel hill
commercial district within a few hours
they had planned the whole thing they
got stages they got a guitarist they got
candles they got you know amplification
system everything and here at six or
seven pm at dusk
you see uh the crowds
at the corners of forbes and murray
and what's important you could see their
umbrellas out that day there was a there
was rain off and on what's really
interesting is what you don't see the
photograph is taken from the steps of
sixth presbyterian church
which for 40 years was the church of mr
rogers fred rogers as all good
pittsburghers know mr rogers was a
pittsburgher he uh taped the show at uh
the public tv station just down the road
from squirrel hill just actually i
actually think it's in squirrel hill
it's technically not the oakland
neighborhood yet there's a lot there's a
lot of controversy to that people will
typically call it oakland but i think
it's still in squirrel hill and mr
rogers was one of the great local you
know allies to the jews a religious
presbyterian an ordained minister in
fact who when he set out to create a
fictional neighborhood mr rogers
neighborhood that represented you know a
world in which children could play and
feel safe and give free range their
imagination he looked out the window of
his house and what he saw was squirrel
hill which is where he lived and and so
literally this is mr rogers neighborhood
and this photograph is taken from the
steps of his church
um the president came politicians do
tend to come to mass killings if they
are
deadly enough which is a a rather
macabre discussion at what at what point
do you qualify for a presidential visit
not at four or five dead but certainly
at 11 dead some people as i discussed
didn't want president trump to come but
ultimately rabbi myers of tree of life
felt that it was his job to offer
hospitality to anyone who came and he
welcomed the president and first lady
and talked with them for about 20
minutes inside the building
here they are outside the building and
you can see
at waist level the uh greg zanus's
crosses for losses with the stars of
david and people's names on the front
you can see sylvan simon bernice simon
daniel stein and melvin wax all you know
inscribed on those stars there was an
anti-trump protest thousands of people
attended that in fact somebody said to
me they thought that the anti-trump
protest was the single largest gathering
of jews in one place in pittsburgh
history which is probably true it was
probably more jews than ever had
gathered in one synagogue building for
rosh hashanah or yom kippur or anything
else it was it was massive
to express their anger at trump they
performed a kind of makeshift uh
korea ritual um those of you who know
the rituals of jewish mourning
know that you often rent a garment when
you hear that a loved one has died and
in modernity you instead of rending the
garment often people will affix a black
ribbon to their outfit and then tear the
black ribbon so to express their grief
and anger at trump what they did what
the organizers did was hand out
thousands of pages pieces of black paper
and then when they gave the signal
everyone went quiet and held the black
paper up to the sky and tore it all at
once so you just heard the tearing as if
there were a rend in the fabric of the
universe at the anti-trump protest now
not everyone was so subtle there was
some
there were some angrier gestures but but
those were pretty rare and in fact the
the protest was overwhelmingly peaceful
there was one arrest and it was an
arrest of someone who was being quite
non-violent this is university of
pittsburgh sociology professor joshua
bloom the only person arrested at the
protest
he sat down in front of trump's
motorcade and began meditating and
chanting and praying and singing and the
police took him away he emphasized to me
when i interviewed him that the police
were quite gentle with him and he was
released the next day and no charges
were pressed
um celebrities come in the aftermath of
a mass killing here you can see uh
another president and first lady that's
tom hanks perhaps the most popular
american ever uh he has his arm around
mr rogers widow joanne rogers this is at
a memorial for the dead i believe in
december a couple months after the
killing
now this is interesting because um
those of you who are football fans will
recognize that lustrous head of white
hair it's robert kraft the owner of the
new england patriots and one of the
things that happens after a mass killing
is when people come to town they want to
pay their respects so
robert kraft who grew up in an observant
jewish home
did come to worship with tree of life
the saturday before the sunday on which
his patriots were to play the steelers
uh tree of life was by the way not in
use and still isn't in use the the
congregations are all worshipping
elsewhere so he's
this tim after services at um wrote a
shalom temple which is where tree of
life has relocated and rented space
there but what's interesting of course
is you'll notice that the owner of the
new england patriots is wearing the
pittsburgh steelers stronger than hate
yamaka and it struck me this is the
first time probably in world history
that the owner of one afc nfl team has
warned the garb of a rival team but he
did it for obvious reasons he was in the
house of of
the steelers and he put it on and
although i don't normally take
photographs on the sabbath i felt like
god wanted me to take out my iphone and
surreptitiously snap a photo of robert
kraft patriots owner wearing steelers
guard
funny stuff in the aftermath of a mass
killing dogs come from hundreds of miles
away if not more therapy dogs support
dogs people who believe that their
animals will help people heal i talked
to one woman from new jersey who brought
a bunch of dogs
many many hours to pittsburgh
i don't know whose dogs these were but
you see them wearing the red vest that
indicate there's some sort of support
animals and you see this girl petting
the dogs and holding a note she had
written for the local police if you
squint you can see that the note says
thank you for keeping the jews in my
neighborhood safe lily age six
you know i'm a dog person and i i i
choke up every time i see this
photograph
and finally i just want to show you the
uh a picture of the
of charming and handsome robert
zacharias who became a friend of mine
holding out a collar that he made
pictures taken by his girlfriend molly
they are lovely people who might whose
company i really got to enjoy
um and i want to i want to tell you
something about robert zechariah so just
just take a look at him take a look at
his beautiful punim and uh and his his
nice smile and countenance and then i
want to read you a bit from the epilogue
of my book i want to conclude by reading
to you
um this bit
about robert zacharias who um
who changed something about himself as a
result of the killing and in the next
three minutes you're going to learn what
the morning of the shooting zack as he
is known had been hanging with a friend
at her apartment in the bloomfield
neighborhood northwest of squirrel hill
after hearing about the killing zach
went home he checked in with his family
and friends and a couple hours later in
mid-afternoon he went to the giant
eagles supermarket to buy soup and
yardside candles small kennels candles
one lights to honor the dead
before he left he dug into his closet
for one of the yamakas he put it on and
left for the market
it was the first time he'd ever worn a
yamaka when it wasn't shabbat or a
jewish holiday or some other special
occasion
he kept the yarmulke on his head at the
havdalah event planned by the high
school students and he has been wearing
one ever since
it is a new experience for me to be
wearing a yamaha out in the world on a
regular basis zach said to me it has
these interesting implications
he mentioned a night when he and his
girlfriend had been trying to decide
where to go out and eat
i was like well gooskies is open and
then i thought wait i heard they have
some nazis at goose keys
zack was referring to the rumor that at
some point some sort of neo-nazi punk
band had played a gig at goose keys a
little dive bar in the polish hill
neighborhood
zach figured that the rumor was probably
false but his head was spinning with
possibility
he thought about the overlap between
punks some of whom lived in polish hill
and various strains of white nationalist
ideology
and he realized that if there were
neo-nazis hanging out at cooskies he now
looked like a target
but i didn't want to take my yamaka off
to go to goose keys and have dinner he
said that didn't feel right
that's some kind of bizarre paying of
obey sentence to the ghost or not ghost
nazis and i don't want to do that but i
also don't want to not go to goose keys
if i want to go to some neighborhood bar
that has vegan kielbasa
the yamaka zach realized complicated
everything if he took it off the
neo-nazis real or imagined would win if
he kept it on but skipped gusky's the
neo-nazis real or imagined would have
deprived him of tasty vegan kielbasa
but if he said yes to the yamaka and
toguski's then he might be putting his
visibly jewish self in sight of the real
or imaginary neo-nazis
now to be clear
there is no evidence actually that
neo-nazis ever hung out at goose because
i did the research on this pure urban
legend
anyway zach weighed his options screwed
up his courage and took himself and his
girlfriend taguski's and when he stepped
inside he took a look around and thought
these aren't anti-semites here he saw a
co-worker of his at the bar reading the
new york times app on his iphone as he
drank a beer and smoked a cigarette it
was all copacetic and couscous
but the yamako is not finished with him
yet
he and his girlfriend sat at the bar and
placed their orders
i made a very expensive order by mistake
zach told me and then i was like oh i
shouldn't get that
he turned away from the bar to look at
his menu to figure out what to order
instead
but as he turned away he noticed the
bartender looking at his yamaka and then
he was immediately concerned that he
would see him changing his order as a
manifestation of his jewishness i was
like oh god damn it now i'm a
money-grubbing jew like i'm complaining
about the expensive order and adjusting
my order to be less expensive so i felt
bad about that because now i'm some sort
of symbol of all the jews
i'm the standard bearer for all these
people whom i don't bear a standard for
he recalled
zach was still feeling like the guy in a
yarmulke who had flagged a problem with
his tab when something happened to
compound his misery
he lifted his bottle of yingling beer to
his mouth to have a sip
and a bit sloshed out and landed on a
man sitting next to him at the bar
it was just a tiny bit of beer and it
seemed the man didn't notice so zach
elected not to say anything
i thought oh he doesn't notice doesn't
matter but no sooner had zach elected to
let the matter drop then the man turned
around he had noticed zach quickly
apologized tried to make everything
right but it was too late i was like i'm
sorry i spilled some beer but i hadn't
said it when i spilled the beer so yet
again i think now i'm a jerk a selfish
unapologetic jew person so it's even
worse everything is bad
zach threw his hands up in despair
it seems that a public jew can never win
so i like ending on that one because
it sort of tells you how far reaching
the ramifications of a mass killing are
right 11 people go to synagogue on
shabbat to three different congregations
inside one building
a white nationalist anti-semite fueled
principally by anti-immigrant sentiment
we can talk about his motivations if he
wants
enters the building
and you know murders 11 people and
wounds two others and then wounds
several of the police who respond
and then if you look at what happens
over the next day and the next week of
sitting shiva and the month of sloshim
and and the whole year of mourning
you discover
that
dogs come
and a medical clown from israel comes to
clown for people
and a guy living a neighborhood or two
over starts running a yamaka and a woman
named lynn hyde living in in the
downtown district hears the sirens go by
on the way to to tree of life and when
she finds out what happens she makes the
decision finally to convert to judaism
something she'd been thinking about for
years and an african-american woman
named rose mckee living outside
minneapolis decides to bake pies for the
victims families and the congregations
and then thinks i believe the jews have
some
dietary laws and she ends up asking the
local jewish day school jewish
elementary school can i use your kitchen
to bake my sweet potato pies because i
want them to be kosher and i understand
i need to use a special kitchen and then
ends up baking the pies there the first
kosher pies she's ever made and then
flying them to pittsburgh to give them
to people you end up seeing these sort
of endless concentric circles of helping
and healing
and loving
and what
i argue implicitly in this book is that
those end up happening much more they
are facilitated by a certain kind of
neighborhood a neighborhood that is both
geographically dense um diverse and
pluralistic not just between jews and
non-jews but of different kinds of jews
that has many many multi-generational
families i kept meeting people who'd
grown up in squirrel hill left and then
moved back there people who were third
and fourth generation squirrel hill
people and so forth so on that basically
everything about the the urbanist
structure of this specific neighborhood
offered lessons about how
you could imagine a community that
should something terrible happen would
not only be able to survive but in some
senses to thrive
and that's what the book is about so
thank you very much
wow mark thank you so much that was uh
just really great and um
you you've such uh you know an amazing
uh talent to capture people's words and
even your your performance of them uh
was just really um
really spectacular so thank you so um a
bunch of questions and i i urge
everybody uh to please use the q a
function um
at the bottom of your screen
um
so um
a few questions that are coming in just
to say more about uh and i'll maybe ask
you a few um
a couple questions together and let you
riff
about more about the neighborhood so
about the specificity
of the neighborhood how you know you
kind of refer to this at the beginning
just how unusual
squirrel hill is as a neighborhood and
um one of my colleagues um
points out that uh she lived in uh the
squirrel hill area as a postdoc in the
1990s that the jewish presence was
really
noticeable as was she remembers a wpa
mural from the depression in the post
office of squirrel hill
that shows a rabbi um in the uh and how
you know struck she was and how unusual
is that to actually have like in a you
know public civil building uh a kind of
you know representation of jewishness
like that yeah well thank you for that i
have a number of thoughts um first of
all
i actually never
either never saw it went in and saw or
never noticed i took note of that mural
there are a lot of wpa murals in post
offices i'm sure this has been written
about where i live in new haven in
westville we have a wpa mural in our
post office and one of the reasons why
we periodically fight to save the post
office when they decide to try to save
money by shutting it down is because it
is so artistically significant i think
um
here i can share actually my screen she
actually helpfully so yeah so
let me see let's work for one second it
would not be surprising that in the 30s
already that there would have been um
you know people taking note of the
jewish presence in squirrel hill because
as i said from the beginning it was a
very religiously
integrated community with a strong
jewish minority they they um the jews at
the point at that point were typically
either in allegheny city or they were in
east liberty they were in other
neighborhoods and pittsburgh was
spreading east and squirrel hill was one
of the easternmost outposts um and it
was hilly and it was nice it initially
had been very tough to settle because um
because it's a hill and the trains that
would carry coal and other kind of
commodities that a neighborhood needs
initially the streetcars couldn't make
it up um all the hills of squirrel hill
and so it you needed some technological
advances before it could be well settled
and then in the late you know i think in
the 1890s or around 1900 they started to
develop it uh it was land purchased by
gentile
developers it was not as if jews said
let's settle here but it quickly became
popular
um with jews uh and and
you know and has stayed
that way um another note that i want to
make before i answer the question
a bit more substantively is that
everywhere i go i now have this magical
superpower of bringing out
ex-pittsburghers who are drawn to this
in a way that i i don't think that if
i'd written a book on cleveland or you
know omaha that i would bring out
clevelanders and omahas but omaha
omahavians but the pittsburgh diaspora
is exceedingly loyal people who've spent
even a year or two there
think of themselves as having lived in
pittsburgh and it's meaningful to them
one thing i would note is that if it
sometimes seems to be the case that you
that everyone knows someone who used to
live in pittsburgh that's partly because
everyone does know someone who used to
live in pittsburgh pittsburgh has a
tremendously populous diaspora because
it only has half the population that it
had 50 years ago so there the world is
filled with people who left pittsburgh
because for a while it's economy
cratered and everyone left and now it is
it is thriving again but it's a
different size
city so it's not accidental that
everywhere i go there are people who
used to live in pittsburgh in a way that
there aren't everywhere i go people used
to live in you know my hometown of
springfield massachusetts um
it has um
you know from the very beginning there
was an orthodox presence which i think
is significant in that the
infrastructure
that communities ha that neighborhood
has often comes from the orthodox in
terms of building a mikvah ritual bath
in terms of some uh some shops that
might be a kosher butcher that might be
a jewish baker um
uh in terms of you know the fact that
you will build up a neighborhood
differently if it has to be um
hospitable to sabbath observant jews you
need um you can't be too far-flung if
you're expecting people to walk a mile
or two or less on saturday to get to
their synagogue so
neighborhoods that cater to and welcome
observant jews sabbath observance jews
are inherently
built for density which is which is why
neighborhoods like west rogers park and
in chicago and um you know squirrel hill
and westville and new haven are often
such lovely properly sized you know
human scale neighborhoods i mean that
that's not accidental they also have to
have really interesting zoning because
you have to be zoned for residential
properties but you also have to allow
houses of worship and you probably have
to allow some commercial properties as
well because people are going to want to
be able to walk especially if they're
having large families they're going to
be able to want to walk to their butcher
their their baker their candlestick
maker so they tend to be neighborhoods
that resist the suburban the
suburbanization and the the kind of
strip multiplication of america better
than most neighborhoods you simply can't
do jewish life on those models you have
to do it on a more old-fashioned
urbanist model and then um you know
squirrel hill also is another advantage
and i don't fully understand why people
have lots of different theories about
why it ended up working so well but it
also has many different sizes of housing
you know i make the point in my book
that you can get into
the taylor alderdice school district
you know for under 200 000 or over a
million i mean it has apartments it has
townhouses it has three family houses it
has mansions and so it just it just
developed really really beautifully but
the most important thing about squirrel
hill as a neighborhood
is that there was a key pivotal moment
when jews worse were heading to the
suburbs in the 60s and 70s and 80s as as
americans do when they have the money
americans of all ethnicities
and the jewish establishment decided not
to move the institutions of the
establishment to the suburbs so unlike
say new haven and most other american
places where they moved the jewish
community center and the day school to
the the first ring suburb in pittsburgh
they they decided to raise money to
rebuild and refurbish all those
institutions right in squirrel hill and
that was a very brave decision there's a
man in howard rieger who was very
instrumental in that who now lives in
chicago and is a real urbanist activist
there
and there had to be on top of all of
those aspects of good fortune there also
had to be some intentionality and so a
lot came together really well
great okay i was not able to share my
screen but that's okay can google um the
mural in the post office okay so a kind
of broader question here it strikes me
listening to your talk that there are
really like two
competing narratives going on here
there's the one that this is a time of
you know the worst anti-semitic attack
in american history
um that was not the only one as we know
there you know have been other ones
including just a couple weeks ago um but
then also you know you really put you
know this emphasis on uh
coming together and people showing up
for jews and you could so the competing
narrative would be that jews have in
fact never been more integrated into
american life possibly into any
culture's life than they are now right
so how how do you wreck how do you think
about those two competing narratives and
how does squirrel hill uh what happened
help us think about them yeah i recently
wrote a piece for the wall street
journal
that in which i pointed out that social
anti-semitism of the kind that kept jews
out of country clubs or out of
partnerships at certain law firms as far
as i can tell is completely gone uh in
america um i'm sure they're last
invested just somewhere and i i've often
said on my podcast you know if anyone
knows of a country club that truly black
balls jews or a law firm that truly
won't make a jewish partner uh let me
know because i want to break that story
but i don't think they exist except as
urban legend anymore so social
anti-semitism of the kind that my
grandparents would have feared he is
basically gone which is which is great
and and is that is not necessarily the
case in all say western european
countries for example my british and
french friends tell me there is a lot of
social anti-semitism um
there you know in the academy and
elsewhere
at the same time things have gotten more
violent over the past 10 years for jews
um principally those being attacked are
jews who either look visibly jewish
because of what they wear as observant
jews or jews who enter any jewish space
whether they are highly observed
themselves or not they've had the
courage to send their children to jewish
day school or to go to synagogue or to
play squash at the jewish community
center and the second you enter a jewish
space you are making yourself a target
some people misread my piece to be
counseling jews to just not enter jewish
spaces it was it was a very interesting
litmus test of how people read it
because i got a lot of mail saying why
are you telling us to just assimilate
more and not enter jewish spaces and i
thought no no i'm one of those jews who
goes to jewish spaces all the time and
i'm saying we're the ones who are
potentially being victimized it doesn't
make us better or worse it's just a
sociological fact that that's where
you'll find the anti-semitism now
i also got a lot of pushback from people
who said well but then there's a big
exception of um college campuses where
it does seem to be writing anti-semitism
and and you know far right and far-left
politics have targeted a lot of jews and
made a lot of jews
afraid of being proudly jewish or um
speaking about zionism in the ways they
want and so forth and so on and
i think that's very real um so
you know what you saw in squirrel hill
you see a kind of amity a kind of
absence of social anti-semitism and an
absence of social suspicion
that
that meant that the gentile allies and
neighbors really rushed to help jews and
indeed
the police rushed to help jews and
that's a very important fact that for
most of jewish history you you know it's
like this in fiddler on the roof god
bless and keep the czar far away from me
right like agents of the state generally
come to either draft you into the tsar's
army or smash your businesses or murder
you and this was the case in which
agents of the state came and put their
bodies you know in between jews and
bullets
and that's a very important fact about
america today the agents of the state
are on our side
um
but
you know this time in which there have
been more
violent attacks on synagogues and on
you know more numerous still
you know non-lethal but still violent
attacks on orthodox jews on the streets
of brooklyn for example than in any
other five or ten year period i can
think of my general sense is that in a
country of 330 million people
they are statistically meaningless the
odds that any given jew is going to be
punched or shot are very very low and i
don't walk around with any anxiety about
it myself however what they do in terms
of the mood and the fearfulness
and the way they provide a litmus test
about how much do gentiles react is
significant so for example i think
there's definitely an anti-jewish bias
in a lot of the mainstream media if you
look at the way that collegeville
collieville was reported in texas it got
far less attention than it would have if
a different if any different minority
group had been um held hostage in their
house of worship there's just no
question that jews don't count as much
um at many media outlets so it's very
complicated
and you know to follow up on what you
were saying about the orthodox um you
know it strikes me that you know there
there are constant attacks on orthodox
jews now i mean i just read about you
know more this week and there is not
that same
um
kumbaya kind of outpouring of
inter-faith i mean or much less than it
seemed no there's not and indeed yeah
and not
not even from other jews i mean the real
the real shonda the real shame there is
what i see as the secular and liberal
jewish um willingness to throw our more
observant brethren and cistern if that's
a word under the bus um that when it's
black-hated jews and their and their
wives um being um
uh
you know
punched and kicked and attacked verbally
and physically in borough park
that um
that
less observant and more acculturated
assimilated jews several miles away
um don't care that much and that's a
that's um
you know is that is that anti-semitism
that's
i mean yeah there's some self-loathing
there's some shame i mean the the
anti-orthodox animus among many
non-orthodox jews is profound and deep
it exists in my own family
and um
you know we're a family of non-orthodox
jews
for the most part all jews have some
relatives who are orthodox um
and i think that that's a that's a
conversation internal conversation that
we we have to deal with but there's a
way in which the visibly obs the visibly
jewish jews are lightning rods who draw
a lot of the violence away a lot of the
physical violence
um away from the rest of us and we have
to think about that yeah
um so um a question from um someone in
the audience who's a grad student who
grew up in squirrel hill and um
you know really appreciates um
uh the relative integration of different
denominations um and the question is how
can other jewish communities learn or
build on squirrel hills example
uh that's a great question i mean the
first thing i always want to say is that
i'm always wary of making prescriptions
or normative claims
about how jews ought to be because
you know unless those jews are my
children in which case i'm all about
ideas for how they should be um as
i have nothing but i you know ways to
hector my own kids but but other
people's kids i try to back off um
the
um
um so you know i'm a journalist i and
and a lapsed historian so i try to just
say you know say things how they are i
don't it's not my job to tell people
what they ought to do
i will say that
you know inevitably my role as my
feelings as a jew and as a citizen
definitely
are inescapable especially in a project
like this and i guess there would be one
basic lesson which is um
to practice what i see squirrel hill
jews practicing which is a kind of intra
faith solidarity that squirrel feels
remarkable for the extent to which you
know secular reform reconstruction
conservative jews know each other and
know the orthodox and you know i make
the point that you'll find a you know
khabad rabbits in power walking with a
reformed jewish woman on a shabbat
afternoon and you'll find
non-orthodox jews at the shabbat tables
of orthodox jews on friday nights and
you'll find just the level of knowledge
and the way in which they're in each
other's lives in squirrel hill partly
because of the intergenerational nature
of it like i would meet orthodox who
said well my grandpa was reform but two
generations later i've gotten more
observant but they stayed in squirrel
hill the whole time so the family ties
go back very deep
i i would just say you know you practice
hospitality and make sure it's a
hospitality toward jews who are not like
you as well as jews who are
it's very simple but it's very hard to
do and most of us including me fall down
on the job
um
yeah so a question about um
how you know what people have done in
squirrel hill but also maybe just more
generally to counter the source of the
tragedy which is the resurgence of of
white nationalism and even outright
nazism uh
can you say a little bit more i mean
they're on the very kind of basic level
there are security measures that you
know most synagogues now have a guard we
didn't used to mostly have a guard my
synagogue now is a good guard i
am a skeptic about how much that would
matter if a well-armed person wanted to
come and kill jews
uh i think
um
i think it might not matter much um the
guard might just be the first person to
get shot after which it might be open
season so um you know i've talked to a
lot of friends who have other ideas
about what security would work rather
than a kind of security theater that i
think we now have which often by the way
proves very expensive a lot of money is
being wasted on bogus security matters
right now um
but
um
in terms of
you know how to counter the ideology i
don't think dudes can counter the i
don't think anyone
jews can't fix anti-semites anti-semites
are soul sick people
um and they're not reacting to jews and
they're not reacting to israel they're
they're
um and they're not reacting to
immigration
they are you know um it's not because to
even go down that line of thinking i
think suggests that there's a kind of
rationale
to anti-semitism there is of course an
internal logic to it in their own brains
it makes some sense but irrational
bigotry um
defeats um
that kind of i mean it's like it's like
cult deprogramming can't be done sure
but it's extremely labor intensive
you know and it's i mean people should
go read the terrific book elizabeth's
book rising out of hatred um about the
former clansman derek black who went to
new college florida where he ended up
leaving he'd been raised in a kind of
clan family very prominent clan family
again the book is zaslow saslo sas low
and it's called rising out of hatred i
think he's a washington post reporter
the best book i've read and you can give
it to an 11 year old like it reads very
easily and my daughter's read it um
totally gripping and this guy went off
to college for some reason he went to a
fairly progressive liberal arts college
and some jews started inviting him to
shabbat dinner
and that's actually what cured him of
his anti-semitism was just knowing jews
so i think we have to practice more
hospitality to all humans but we should
do that anyway because it's a mitzvah
that we're called on to do i don't think
we can worry much about how to cure
anti-semites
okay great well that brings us exactly
to the end of our program so i just want
to thank you so much um on behalf of
everyone who you can't see who i'm sure
are they're all silently clapping at
home um thank you i urge everyone to to
buy the book and um really thank you
again mark uh it was really a
fascinating discussion so well
you and and the community around you
have been a huge source of support and
i'm excited to meet everyone in person
when when that's possible so thanks
again exactly okay and thank you to
everyone
who showed up
bye-bye